[Music]
from the tip of every branch like a fat
purple fig a wonderful future beckoned
and winked
but choosing one meant losing all the
rest and as i sat there unable to decide
the figs began to wrinkle and go black
and one by one they plopped to the
ground at my feet
in this passage from sylvia plaths the
bell jar a young woman imagines an
uncertain future and speaks to the
universal fear of becoming paralyzed by
the prospect of making the wrong choice
although she considered other careers
plath chose the artist's way poetry was
her calling
under her shrewd iron pen everyday
objects became haunting images a new
statue in a drafty museum a shadow in a
mirror a slab of soap
fiercely intelligent penetrating and
witty plath was also diagnosed with
clinical depression she used poetry to
explore her own states of mind in the
most intimate terms and her breathtaking
perspectives on emotion nature and art
continue to captivate and resonate
in her first collection of poems the
colossus she wrote of a feeling of
nothingness
white it is a complexion of the mind
at the same time she found solace in
nature from a blue mist dragging the
lake to white flowers that tower and
topple to blue mussels clumped like
bulbs
after the colossus she published the
bell jar her only novel which
fictionalizes the time she spent working
for mademoiselle magazine in new york
during college
the novel follows its heroine esther as
she slides into a severe depressive
episode but also includes wickedly funny
and shrewd depictions of snobby fashion
parties and dates with dull men
shortly after the publication of the
bell jar plath died by suicide at age
30.
two years later the collection of poems
she wrote in a burst of creative energy
during the months before her death was
published under the title ariel
widely considered her masterpiece ariel
exemplifies the honesty and imagination
plath harnessed to capture her pain
in one of ariel's most forceful poems
lady lazarus she explores her attempts
to take her own life through lazarus the
biblical figure who rose from the dead
she writes and i a smiling woman i am
only thirty and like the cat i have nine
times to die
but the poem is also a testament to
survival i rise with my red hair and i
eat men like air
this unflinching language has made plath
an important touchstone for countless
other readers and writers who sought to
break the silence surrounding issues of
trauma frustration and sexuality
ariel is also filled with moving
meditations on heartbreak and creativity
the title poem begins stasis in darkness
then the substanceless blue
poor of tour and distances
this sets the scene for a naked ride on
horseback in the early morning one of
plath's most memorable expressions of
the elation of creative freedom but it
is also full of foreboding imagery
such as a child's cry that melts in the
wall
and a red eye the cauldron of mourning
this darkness is echoed throughout the
collection which includes controversial
references to the holocaust and the
kamikazes
even the relics of seemingly happier
times are described as crucifying the
author my husband and child smiling out
of the family photo their smiles catch
onto my skin little smiling hooks
her domestic dissatisfaction and her
husband's mistreatment of her are
constant themes in her later poetry
after her death he inherited her estate
and has been accused of excluding some
of her work from publication
despite these possible omissions and her
untimely death what survives is one of
the most extraordinary bodies of work by
a 20th century poet while her work can
be shocking in its rage and trauma plath
cast her readers as witnesses
not only to the truth of her
psychological life but her astounding
ability to express what often remains
inexpressible
if like plath there is a voice within
you that will not be still it is time to
start writing check out these animations
for the guidance you need to put pen to
paper
[Music]
you